.
THAT'S HELL ON EARTH.
TWO OF HIS FRIENDS SHOT IN FRONT
OF HIM, ANOTHER BLOWN UP WITH A
GRENADE.
MASS GRAVES ALL OVER NORTHERN
UKRAINE FILLED WITH THE BODIES
OF INNOCENT CIVILIANS.
MORE THAN 300 PEOPLE WERE JUST
BURIED OUT SO I OF BUCHA.
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS SQUATTED IN
HOMES FOR WEEKS, EATING THEIR
FOOD AND GETTING DRUNK ON THEIR
LIQUOR.
ALL TOLD, THE HORROR, THE
INHUMANITY, THIS OCCUPATION OF
PUTIN'S WAR HAS BEEN
UNIMAGINABLE.
SOUTH OF KYIV IN THE SIEGE CITY
OF MARIUPOL, WE GO BACK THERE.
THE CONDITIONS GET WORSE EVERY
DAY.
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE SOLITARY
BUILDING IN THE CITY HAS BEEN
TORCHED OR LEVELED BY RUSSIAN
SHELLING.
THERE'S NO POWER, THERE'S NO
WATER, THERE'S NO FOOD, THERE'S
NO SUPPLIES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CIVILIANS
ARE TRAPPED, CUT OFF FROM THE
WORLD AS RUSSIA'S ONSLAUGHT
CONTINUES.
SOME WERE KILLED BY CLUSTER
BOMBS, OTHERS DIE OF STARVATION.
IT'S AN APOCALYPTIC SCENE WITH
EXTREME DEATH TOLL.
EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK, THERE'S
EVIDENCE OF WAR CRIMES.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS BLOOD IS
ON ONE MAN'S HANDS, VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
THESE PEOPLE DIED ALL BECAUSE OF
HIS TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS.
THAT OF A MURDERING DICTATOR
THUG.
TONIGHT THE U.S. CAN DO A LOT TO
END THIS WAR.
THEY CAN HELP DRIVE RUSSIA OUT
OF UKRAINE ONCE AND FOR ALL IN
SPITE PEOPLE LYING ABOUT ME
SAYING HANNITY IS CALLING FOR
AMERICAN TROOPS ON THE GROUND.
I AM NOT.
WE DON'T NEED A NO FLY ZONE BUT
WE CAN'T START WORLD WAR III
WITH PUTIN'S RUSSIA.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE HAVE SHOWN
VALOR, COURAGE TO FIGHT FOR
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
WE CAN TAKE A PAGE OUT OF THE
REAGAN DOCTRINE INSTEAD OF
SENDING IN WAVES OF U.S. GROUND
TROOPS TO FOREIGN LANDS IN A
LONG BLOODY CONVENTIONAL WAR,
REAGAN ARMED OUR ALLIES, ARMED,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE MOOGAHADINE.
THEY DEFEATED THE FORMER SOVIET
UNION IN THE 80s.
ALSO, RONALD REAGAN HELPED THE
FREEDOM FIGHTERS, THE CONTRA
REBELS.
THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL.
BIDEN COULD DO THE SAME THING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH NATO COUNTRIES
AND WESTERN EUROPEAN COUNTCOUNT.
TWO THINGS NEED TO HAPPEN.
ONLY TWO.
AMERICAN AND WESTERN EUROPEAN
WEAPONS ARE NOT GETTING TO
UKRAINE FAST ENOUGH.
I DO BLAME OUR LETHARGIC FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE NEED TO SEE THE URGENCY.
THEY'RE FIGHTING IT IN REAL
TIME, NOT THROUGH SOME
BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE AND SLOW
LEADERSHIP.
THEY NEED A CONSTANT FLOW OF
STINGERS, JAVELINS, DRONES,
ANTI-MISSILE, ANTI-AIRCRAFT
SYSTEMS AND AMMUNITION IN THE
HANDS OF THE UKRAINIANS AND THEY
NEED IT WITHOUT DELAY.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S A NINE-HOUR FLIGHT FROM
WASHINGTON D.C. TO POLAND.
THAT'S IT.
YOU CAN DO IT VERY QUICKLY.
NUMBER 2, OUR ALLIES IN EUROPE,
THEY NEED TO STOP FUNDING THE
WAR.
BY FUNDING IT, I'M TALKING ABOUT
COUNTRIES LIKE GERMANY, MANY
OTHER WESTERN COUNTRIES, THEY
CONTINUE TO PURCHASE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF OIL AND GAS FROM
RUSSIA.
GUESS WHAT?
THAT MONEY IS GOING INTO PUTIN'S
POCKET AND THAT HELPS HIM FUND
THIS WAR.
IT'S KEEPING HIS ECONOMY AFLOAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY THEY.
WE CAN GET OUR ALLIES FINALLY
THE ENERGY THAT THEY NEED.
GUESS WHAT?
BUT WE HAVE TO BE WILLING TO
PRODUCE IT HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ANYWHERE WE CAN IN
THE INTERIM.
THEY HAVE TO BE WILLING TO CUT
RUSSIA OFF ONCE AND FOR ALL.
HOW MANY MORE CARNAGE DOES
EUROPE AND THE U.S. NEED TO SEE?
YOU NEED TO GET UKRAINE THE
WEAPONS THAT THEY NEED, QUIT
BUYING RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS.
IF THE FREE WORLD CAN SOMEHOW
MANAGE TO DO THOSE T